le principal pilier de l'équipe de
france c'est son numéro 10 inédits
zidane il joue habituellement à la juan
en italie zidane qui est originaire de
la castellane l'un des quartiers les
plus défavorisés de marseille une cité
qu'il a quitté lorsqu'il avait 13 ans
mais il nous reste une idole il s'occupe
d'ailleurs du petit club de la nouvelle
vague
morad aït habbouche christian de carnets
une cité parmi tant d'autres des
quartiers nord de marseille
nous sommes à la castellane plus de 6600
personnes vivent ici un air de favelas
ces quartiers miséreux du brésil dans
ses tours hlm
il y a en fait autant de nationalités
que deux pays qualifié pour le mondial
et c'est là sur cette dalle que zizou a
fait ses premiers pas ses premiers
dribbles ne cherchait pas un graffiti
une référence à leur idole
non zinédine zidane l'enfant de la cité
est dans tous les coeurs sur toutes les
lèvres mais zidane ouzou du club et on a
beau larsen croit aux vertus du football
en 91 cet ami d'enfance de zidane a créé
une structure un club
voilà devant le siège de la nouvelle
vague
déjà 200 licenciés et autant de rêves
entretenir l'école album nous avons
quand même un niveau assez bas du que
les parents c'est la plupart sont des
enfants d'immigrés qui n'ont pas été à
l'école ils peuvent pas suivre leur
scolarité derrière alors faire les
devoirs
c'est bien dommage donc ce processeur il
cherche à réussir pour qu'un jour leurs
copains les admire à leur tour sur ce
petit écran
d'ores et déjà tous les yeux de la
castellane demain seront braqués sur
zizou leur faute de la cité